I have to drink Catefarm protein drinks to gain weight. I get horrible gas from the
drinks. They all make me feel below that any suggestions. Okay, so so really
Catefarm protein drinks aren't gonna make you really gain a whole lot of weight. If
you want to gain weight you have to eat more carbohydrates. That's just the
general rule. It doesn't mean that people are deficient, can't be deficient in
protein. I'm not sure what's in the Catefarm protein drinks. I would suggest if
you're going to do a protein drink that you use that you use the US enzymes
brand. Sounds like a really tip on the US enzymes brand but but the reason why we
carry that and we only recommend the US enzymes brand and they have a
vanilla and or a chocolate is because it's low in glutamate. So I don't know
what Catefarm's glutamate levels are in that but the US enzymes brand chocolate
or vanilla is low in glutamate. A lot of our cancer members are using that. It
actually tastes really good in a shape too. It's good. And these are again the reason
why I like US enzymes is the cleatness of the source. They are literally
anal about their their purity of their supple that's more than any other
company in something. That's why they have such a small line because they're so
strict with their their rigid with their requirements. But and so fully
answer that question. What do you do when you get gas or bloating after you eat
anything? Okay, why do you get that? Well the reason why you get that is because
you're improper digestion. So now you could get gas and bloating because you just
ate you know a chili with a whole bunch of beans which produced a whole bunch of
gas. And okay, well that may be not be a good example. But even at that how can
one person eat chili and get a little bit of gas not so mad at them and another
person ate same amount of chili and they're just totally gassy and bloated. It's
because of improper digestion. So the answer to that is you take a some sort of
digestive enzymes with your meal. So you either take you know digestive enzymes
like US enzymes digestimes or you can take the HCl sign by US enzyme or you can
take our clear digest understand US enzymes parent company makes a lot of the
enzymes that they then sell to most the other supplement company. So most of the
digestive enzymes in any good supplements are actually US enzymes enzymes. So unless
you're buying something at Walmart or something like that, anything you buy at our
store we have the clear digest private labels and designs for health. It's the US
enzymes enzyme. Even now brand uses US enzymes enzymes. So HCl plus a
digestive enzymes helps break down more food in your gut in your stomach I mean and
then the digestive enzymes help break down more of the proteins in your intestinal
tract. So if you're ever bloated or a lot of gas and why am I getting that you have
improper digestion you need to start taking digestive enzymes with your food.